العلاقات بين القوه العظمى في العالم
تدهورت اكثر فاكثر بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه
والبشريه تنجرف الى واحده من اخطر الفترات
النوويه في التاريخ مع ارتفاع مشاهدينا
حده الحديث عن التهديد بالنوويه وسباق
التسلح يقول هنا معهد ستوكه الدولي
للابحاث ولابحاث السلام وهنا لابد من
التوقف عند الدول التسع التي تمتلك اسلحه
نوويه في العالم وهي طبعا كما نشاهد هنا
الولايات المتحده وروسيا وفرنسا والصين
والهند وباكستان وكوريا الشماليه
وبريطانيا وغيرها ولكن خارج حدود هذه
الدول اين تنشر الولايات المتحده وروسيا
والصين الترسانه النوويه التابعه لها
التقديرات هنا تشير الى ان القنابل
النوويه المنشوره استراتيجيا خارج الاراضي
الامريكيه تتراوح بين 100 و 200 قنبله
نوويه في اوروبا تحديدا في المانيا
وبلجيكا وايطاليا وهولندا وتركيا اما
روسيا فاعلنت لاول مره منذ انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي بانها ستنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
على ارض اراضي جاراتها وحليفتها بيلاروسيا
وذلك طبعا مع ارتفاع حده الصراع في
اوكرانيا اما الصين مشاهدينا فقد عمدت
خلال السنوات الاخيره الى توسيع قدراتها
العسكريه بشكل ملحوظ طبعا مع التركيز على
التحديث الترسانه النوويه وتستعد بكين هنا
لبدء مفاعل نووي جديد تحديدا على الساحل
الصيني قرب تايوان اي على بعد
135 ميلا فقط من تايوان لحمايه امنها وفق
قولها الصين طبعا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات